my name is Joanne Freeman and I'm a
professor
history and American Studies here at
Yale and I specialize in early national
political history usually I write about
the founders but right now I'm working
on a book which you'll be hearing about
this afternoon that's kind of yanked me
all the way up to the Civil War and I
want to welcome you first of all those
of you who are not normally at Yale to
Yale to this inauguration weekend which
I'm really honored to be a part of and
to my talk this afternoon which I've
titled the field of blood congressional
violence in antebellum America and I'll
explain that title in just a couple of
minutes and let me say at the outset I'm
fighting a cold so if I clear my throat
I'm not suggesting anything important by
the clearing of the throat I'm just
clearing my throat now I assure you when
I decided to give this particular talk
on this particular occasion I could not
possibly have imagined how topical it
would come dazeem my plan was and still
is really to give you a sneak preview
into the book that I've been working on
for a good number of years and I'm now
in the process of completing it and as
the title suggests and I think the blurb
and some of the promotional material
suggests it's a book about congressional
violence in the first half of the 19th
century or to be more specific between
about 1830 and the Civil War now along
the lines of what I just said I have to
start out with a confession and that is
given the way that our current political
situation has been evolving I've been
kind of agonizing over this lecture
because I want to be informative and I
want to reveal some what I think are
really interesting things to you I also
want to amuse you a little bit and I was
nervous because I thought how am I going
to amuse you in addition to informing
you in a climate where so many people
are angry at Congress and I got an email
a couple of about 10 days ago which I
want to mention only because I think it
gave me the answer about how to approach
this and it actually was from an aide to
a prominent Republican in the house who
shall go nameless and who contacted me
with the question and he had been in
touch with me once
and this will be a little Gail
promotional moment here
he'd been in touch with me once before
because as some of you may already know
Yael has been putting some of its
lecture courses online in a program
called open Yale courses and my my
American Revolution course is online and
this particular aid had seen it and he
liked it and he was nice enough to
contact me and say so so that was nice
but he contacted me again about ten days
ago and he said that he realized I was
busy that I probably didn't have time to
respond but he was in what he called a
state of despair about Congress which
isn't what you wanna hear from the
inside maybe from the outside not from
the inside um and he basically just
wanted historical perspective he wanted
me just to say something about Congress
to give him some kind of insight maybe
to suggest that this sort of thing has
happened before and I suppose in some
way to make him feel a little bit better
and so what I wanted to this afternoon
is offer you some historical perspective
by talking about and to be blunt it all
boils down to this congressmen behaving
badly in the first half of the 19th
century now I am gonna stay firmly
planted in the 19th century there is a
reason that I'm a historian and that is
I really do like to stay in the past
and particularly at times like the place
at like the present the past is a very
nice place to be so I'm not offering
answers I'm not commenting on the
current Congress I'm really offering
information and insights but I'll
conclude with an interesting parallel I
think between the 19th century Congress
and the current Congress that I at least
think is kind of evocative and hopefully
you'll agree and I'm going to talk about
my topic this afternoon by posing and
answering for pretty logical questions
so first off what are we talking about
when we talk about congressional
violence number two why was it happening
number three why didn't anyone stop it
and number four what was its ultimate
impact what does it suggest so let's
start at the beginning question number
one what are we talking about when we
talk about congressional violence and
I'll start by saying there was a lot of
it I've been digging for it for a good
many years and at this point I found at
least 125 instances of physical violence
in the House and the Senate
between as I said roughly 1830 in the
Civil War and that's not comprehensive
by any means as a matter of fact not
only is it not comprehensive but on
Thursday morning I was testing out a
database that the library was
considering purchasing of British
newspapers from the 19th century and I
thought wow you know I'm totally
single-minded here I'll just punch in a
search that relates to my book and see
what happens and Bing I think came up
with a new fight thanks to the British
press which they then checked and I
can't resist I just have to read you the
headline because well you'll hear part
of the headline to strikes me as kind of
amusing it's from 1852 and it started
out in the British press this is
actually from the Boston Herald because
then I had to prove to myself that this
really happened and the headline in the
Boston Herald is disgraceful proceedings
in Congress fight between Brown and
Wilcox on the floor of the house and
this is the part of the title the
headline that I like black eyes etc it
was like I like the etcetera you all
know what happens with the black eyes so
obviously as suggested by that by
violence I actually mean violence I mean
duels and duel negotiations shoving and
fistfights people pulling bowie knives
and pistols on the floor waving them
around at each other big wild melees
usually in the house with dozens of men
rolling around in the aisles slugging
each other pulling each other's hair a
few street fights with fists bricks and
the occasional umbrella and a few fights
in the Willard hotel which for some
reason was a congressional violence
magnet whenever I'm in Washington I
always stay at Hotel in honor of my book
and of course I also mean canings
beatings with canes like the most
notorious instance of congressional
violence which is the caning of Senator
Charles Sumner in 1856 and you know I'd
say over the years whenever I mentioned
this project to anyone 99% and I would
say a hundred percent but as a historian
I'm never feel comfortable saying a
hundred percent of the time about
anything but 99% of the time if I
mentioned this project people will say
oh yeah there was that guy and they'll
usually do this
which is charles sumner and that caning
as I said unquestionably the most famous
violent incident in congressional
history and as a matter of fact the
title of my book and the title of this
talk comes from a letter written to
Sumner after the caning and a friend of
Sumner's wrote to him and said quote
that blood would flow somebody's blood
before the expiration of your present
session on that field of blood the floor
of Congress I have fully expected so to
this correspondent and I thank this
correspondent for giving me the title of
my book the floor of Congress was quite
literally the field of blood because of
all the violence now all of this
violence given what I'm suggesting here
raises an obvious question and that is
why in the world haven't historians and
scholars discovered it before and the
answer is partly because people haven't
been looking for it but more than that
the violence hasn't been found because
much of it was essentially censored out
of the periods equivalent of the
Congressional Record and the reason for
this was because of the nature of the
Washington press in this period in the
1830s the Washington press consisted of
a handful of men working for a handful
of local newspapers and they couple of
them sat in the house a couple of them
sentence Senate and they scribbled notes
and then published their accounts of the
debates in spin-off publications from
the newspapers that they wrote for and
the spin-off publications basically
acted as the Congressional Record and
the newspapers that they were working
for were unquestionably and
unapologetically partisan so objective
news had not become a goal at this point
in time so newspapers were basically
party organs and party members and
particularly in Congress supported their
newspaper in part by providing lucrative
government printing contracts so if you
were a Washington reporter this meant
that you really really wanted to keep
the congressman in your own party very
happy they gave you printing contracts
they gave you inside information and if
they weren't happy they might beat you
up which happened more than once so you
wanted to report congressmen
particularly those on your side of the
aisle in the way that they wanted to be
reported and they weren't always eager
to be
reported saying and doing what they were
actually saying and doing and so for
this reason a lot of this violence
actually isn't in the record and there's
actually a really comical footnote in
one of the periods equivalent to the
Congressional Record and it follows this
obviously really carefully worded report
of a really angry debate in which
clearly insults were being tossed around
but the insults aren't listed there's
there's and I'll come back in a minute
typically what you tend to find when
violence is not being mentioned in the
record but so there's this weird cryptic
description of something happening and
you can kind of tell it's unpleasant and
then on the very bottom of the page the
reporter writes and I'm gonna paraphrase
it here he basically says you know a
reporter can't be too careful these days
so I'm not gonna record what I actually
heard during that debate it was just too
angry and that's actually typical of the
sort of thing that you find and again
this is part of why people no one has
found this before you find clues about
the violence but you don't find the
actual violence so sometimes you'll see
something that says for example the
debate became unpleasantly personal at
one time that usually means men are
slugging each other more more often than
not men are punching each other in one
case one pulled a gun on another in one
of those unpleasantly personal moments
or you see a comment like there was a
sensation in the corner that particular
quote comes from an instance when two
congressmen began punching each other
and flipped over their desks that was a
sensation or often you'll see a
congressman rise to his feet and say
very formally something along the lines
of it gives me great pleasure to report
that mr. X and mr. Y have made mutual
apologies to each other and the matter
is settled and sometimes there actually
is applause at that kind of a moment but
usually there is absolutely no
information about what mr. X and mr. Y
said or did to require a public apology
so you can see why it's taken me years
to find this congressional violence
often I have to resort to private
letters and diaries and obviously
digging through them can be pretty
random so we have at least 125 fights in
roughly a 30 year period why which
brings us to question number two
I all the violence the easy answer but
only a very partial answer is that the
young American Republic was an extremely
violent place and Congress was
representative the new nation was still
defining itself in a lot of ways it was
expanding across the continent it was
deciding some pretty fundamental
questions in the process and obviously
the question of slavery was a major one
politics was particularly violent and I
think it's easy to forget that our
country was once so young and so
experimental that people had to figure
out what precisely a democratic politics
was it took learning it took practice
there was no precise example that the
United States could follow for what it
was doing and sometimes that learning
process could be violent I mean in a way
we see this all over the world today
this was true as well in early America
elections featured all kinds of mayhem
there were riots there were canings
there were duels there was an election
riot in Washington in the 1850s that was
so rowdy and uncontrolled that they
called in the Marines to disperse the
election and the the crowd and the
Marines really dispersed the crowd
because they accidentally killed a few
people in trying to clear people out of
the way I think they fired a cannon
which maybe was not the best way to
clear a crowd of people rioting and at
the next election in Washington when
only one or two people were killed you
find people in their diary breathing a
sigh of relief that it was a normal
election in which there only one or two
deaths as opposed to many deaths so
politics is violent and legislators all
over the country
occasionally collapsed into mass Rumbles
I think the prize for state legislative
violence goes to Arkansas is there
anyone here from Arkansas No okay then
I'm safe Arkansas in the 1830s is the
most extreme example and there was some
debate going on in the Arkansas State
House someone on the floor insulted the
speaker and the speaker responded by
coming down from the podium and stabbing
the legislator to death he was then
tried and found not guilty for excusable
homicide so that really must have been
some him
that was excusable and reelected which
tells you something about what seemed
normal in the realm of political
violence and in fact there are a number
of congressmen in this period who did
some pretty serious crimes before
winning election to Congress including
murder and there were some people who
quite literally wanted fighters fighting
for them in Congress and I'm going to
come back to that idea in just a few
minutes but political violence was not
restricted to Arkansas there were brawls
in legislatures all over the country
like one in the Massachusetts state
legislature that prompted a New York
Times reporter to report quote there was
a most heavenly time in the house for an
hour - it would have made a sensation
even in Congress which suggests and it's
true
Congress was indeed the national capital
of legislative violence at this time
which brings us to a deeper reason for
congressional violence which is bound up
with the fact that Congress is a
national institution Congress brings
together people from all over the
country and in the young United States
which was still so local and sectional
in its orientation different parts of
the country played the political game
differently and had different feelings
about the acceptability of individual
man-to-man violence generally speaking
southern and southern born Western
congressmen tended to be more violent
they were more likely to be armed
they were quicker to throw a punch and
they were more likely to willingly fight
a duel and northerners and northern born
Western congressmen were slower to
resort to physical violence and
generally uncomfortable with dueling so
to use congressional terms and these are
actually congressmen tended to break
their ranks into two kinds of men these
are actually they're terms as a
historian when your historical sources
provide you with unbelievable statements
quotations or phrases it makes you so
happy and this is an example of that
some men were called quote unquote
fighting men and other men were called
quote unquote non-combatants and
Congress tended to understand that some
in their ranks were won and some in
their ranks were another now you could
already guess that generally speaking
this dynamic might give southerners
something
of an advantage during debate because
northerners sometimes we're more likely
to back down rather than inflame a
southerner and I want to offer you and
it's actually from that same thing that
I just found two days ago but as long as
I have it I'm going to just quote you an
example of an inflamed southerner in a
violent incident in this one that
resulted in black eyes apparently one of
them they're both from Mississippi and
one of them said there are no
secessionist in Mississippi and the
other one said yes there are and the
first one said are you saying I'm lying
and the second one said well I suppose
that is what I just said isn't it and
then the first one slugged him and then
there was a fight so this is how the
newspaper reports what happened
Wilcox who's one of them jumped from his
desk and cried I can whip him let me go
waving his arms in the air cries of
where's the sergeant at arms stop the
fighting my god as Wilkins got a knife
no no I don't think he has one a hundred
voices joined in the confusion calling
for the sergeant at arms
the officers etc several of the runner
boys the pages were knocked over in the
excitement and the greatest alarm
prevailed and the account closes with
this very literal description of the
speaker trying to get control of the
house and I'll read it only because I
can't quite believe how literally
descriptive it is the speaker trying to
get control knocked is what it says
basically uses the word knocked saying
in the intervals the chair knock well
here knock no proposition until order
knock knock knock is restored so it
gives you what I love is it and this is
not the only account that I found in
which they people the reporter or the
diarist
actually records what it sounded like
that's an influence southerners that's
kind of typical for what a congressional
fight might be like but that one is
clearly somewhat spontaneous some
violence was not spontaneous some of it
was actually quite deliberate and
strategic and here we come to one
central reason for congressional
violence because when important issues
were at stake fighting men largely
southerners pushed their advantage they
threatened and screamed and insulted and
bullied to silence non-combatants or to
steer their votes
so in essence given the regional
mix of men in Congress bullying and
fighting were politically useful they
were a way of claiming power on the
floor and men who deliberately deployed
this strategy of debate were known and
again this is the 19th century term for
it they were known as bullies you see a
lot of mention in newspapers of bullies
now I actually know nothing about hockey
but whenever I talk about congressional
bullies to anyone who knows anything
about hockey as I've now learned there
are people in hockey called hockey
enforcers and the enforcers their job is
to intimidate people on the opposing
team with threats and violence so
bullies are the congressional equivalent
of hockey enforcers which is a sentence
that I never thought would come out of
my mouth but is the truth and I want to
offer you just one or two examples of
bullying so you can see what I'm talking
about here the first one took place in
1842 when Thomas Arnold a Tennessee Whig
objected to the fact that Southern
Democrats kept silencing John Quincy
Adams to Southern Democrats responded by
coming over to Arnold seat and one of
them very visibly wearing a bowie knife
and threatened to cut Arnold's throat
quote from ear to ear if he ever
objected to a Democrat ever again that's
clear bullying example number two shows
the overall impact of this kind of
bullying and it takes place in 1837 when
freshman representative Joshua Giddings
in Ohio Whig discovered that another
congressman was unfairly claiming a
government per diem and he wanted to
object but his northern friends told him
he'd better shut up and not say anything
because the congressman collecting the
per diem was a duelist and getting's
Micah killed if he piped up and objected
so here you really see the underlying
often invisible impact of congressional
bullying you see men who are too afraid
to speak trying to silence someone else
from speaking up now there are patterns
in this kind of bullying in the 1830s
and much of the 1840s fights tended to
be largely about party
conflict both parties the Whigs and the
Democrats had their share of bullies who
did their best to promote their party
and intimidate the other party and in
this way national parties were kind of
useful because they spread around the
power of southern bullying and gave
northerners and southerners a good
reason to appease each other and
compromise with each other so at first
bullying and violence were party
oriented later in the 1850s they became
more sectional and more centered around
slavery and I'm going to come back to
that idea in just a few minutes so the
answer to question number two why was
there so much violence is largely
because it was useful it actually
accomplished something for at least some
people which leads very naturally to
question number three why didn't someone
stop the violence now one obvious answer
to that question relates to what I just
said which is well some people thought
it was highly useful so they wanted it
to continue but there were other reasons
why the violence persisted a very big
one being that it was very hard to stand
up and object to it without seeming
cowardly and you can see this by looking
at what congressman said when they did
stand up and object to the violence
every now and then and this would
particularly be the case if there was a
mass brawl or a rumble with dozens of
congressmen something really sort of
outrageous someone would stand up
usually a noncombatant and bemoan the
state of congress in speeches that
basically always said what's happening
to congress what is happening to the
state of the nation this violence is
shameful we must do something these
speeches were common enough that John
Quincy Adams actually made up his own
name for them in his diary he refers to
them as lamentation speeches so he'll
describe it'll say in his diary
mr. Smith hit mr. Jones over the head
and then the lamentation speeches
started so the same sorts of speeches
but what's interesting about them is
usually they would have two parts the
first part would be the what's happening
to Congress this is shameful something
should be done what is with the violence
this violence is shameful the second
part would be but of course I'm not
afraid of the violence I'm not afraid of
anyone I'm willing to fight everyone I'm
not scared I'm just speaking generally
about the institution of Congress there
was always chest beating involved after
the sort of objectia
to the congressional violence no one
wanted to seem cowardly this same kind
of logic convinced virtually every
congressman embroiled in a fight to
surrender his congressional privilege of
debate his right not to be held
personally accountable for what he said
on the floor and that's pretty much a
fundamental foundation a free and fair
legislative debate that you will not be
held personally accountable for what you
say during debate but most congressmen
when embroiled in a tangle would declare
that they were willingly surrendering
their privilege of debate because it
would be cowardly to hide behind it so
one of the reasons why the violence
persisted is because it was hard to
object to it without seeming cowardly in
addition Congress did its best to
regulate the violence it didn't try to
stop it
which I think given how violent the
times were and given that some people
thought it was useful would not have
worked anyway
but when it came to fighting Congress
did have an interest in keeping it fair
and keeping Congress functional and it's
kind of counterintuitive but in fact
congressional violence reveals Congress
acting like a community helping to forge
public apologies enforcing unwritten
rules of fair fighting basically keeping
things fair and there's a great example
of this from the 1850s and there's an
account from a congressman who describes
sitting at his desk and he glasses up
and he sees standing across the desk
from one of his colleagues at stranger
glowering with his fists clenched right
and so this fellow who sees this
immediately thinks oh well there's gonna
be a fight there and as he describes his
actions he says he looked at his
colleague and he looked at the stranger
and he thought well my colleague is a
bigger guy so he could probably lick him
in a fight and he went back to work it
was gonna be a fight but my friend will
win few minutes later he looks up and
sure enough the fight has begun and
they're fighting but when he noticed
what he thought might be a gun in the
jacket of the stranger he ran over and
positioned himself behind the stranger
didn't stop the fight just ready to grab
his arm if he reached for the weapon
because an armed man fighting an unarmed
man would be unfair but the fight itself
was fair and so
was going to let it continue and that's
not the only instance of that in which
and as a matter of fact famously that
happens during the caning of Sumner as
well in which someone says stand back
it's a fair fight that happens a lot in
fights as long as that seems fair a fair
fight by the sort of bluntest most
primitive of terms people would let
these men fight and sort of clear their
name so violence was useful violence was
strategic and often it was seen as fair
but as I suggested before it did seem to
give some an advantage to southerners so
what happened when national political
parties combining northerners and
southerners into one team essentially
collapsed in the 1850s and this brings
us to question number four what was the
impact of this violence and what does it
suggest and the answer to this question
does lie in the 1850s in the decade
leading up to the Civil War
now I'll confess to you that as a
historian I usually resist prevailing
assumptions about anything until I see
primary evidence from the period that
I'm studying that proves that it's true
and in my first book which was about
essentially what it felt like to be a
politician on the national stage in the
first decade of our government under the
Constitution
I refuse to assume that there was a
first party system until I saw evidence
that there was one and I never saw that
evidence
I saw temporary alliances I never saw
party discipline I didn't see real
parties I certainly didn't see a system
so the equivalent in the case of this
book is there's a prevailing assumption
that national politics was sort of
swimming along in the first half of the
nineteenth century and that there were
crises and compromises and crises and
compromises until the 1850s when things
suddenly got worse and then we had a
civil war well although I started out
the project refusing to assume that this
was true in fact congressional violence
did get much worse in the 1850s
although national politics was not
necessarily swimming along happily
before that point part of what I'm
showing in my book is that the Civil War
had some very long roots but things did
suddenly get much worse in the 1850s but
why what does this suggest about the
impact of congressional violence
well generally speaking things got more
violent in that decade for a few reasons
for one thing as I've already suggested
national political parties began to
collapse so southerners and northerners
weren't working in league as much as
before and there were thus fewer
restraints on fighting men national
parties can be handy organizational
things that encourage compromise even in
the case of antebellum America sectional
compromise and here they were collapsing
also in the 1850s things got more
violent because at the same time that
national parties were collapsing
sectional parties were rising like the
Republican Party which was essentially a
northern party and the sectional issue
of slavery was coming to the fore as
well and in addition in the 1850s there
was stronger and more organized
anti-slavery sentiment in the north and
more anti-slavery sense congressmen in
Congress and this contributed to
congressional violence as well but in
addition the press played a role in
fueling congressional violence in the
1850s because the press changed in this
period beginning in the mid to late
1840s during this general period of time
there were big technological changes
first you get the steam-powered printing
press then you get the railroads then
you get the Telegraph and when you put
these things together they helped the
press become far more national and reach
and far faster in its ability to spread
news around than before so news could
spread faster and further the audience
watching congressional proceedings was
broader and more national than ever
before people in different parts of the
country could see what other parts of
the country were saying in their
newspapers faster than ever before they
were out of town reporters sitting in
the visitors gallery in the Capitol
building writing columns about Congress
that were communicated throughout the
country pretty quickly more than ever
before and congressmen didn't know often
even who these out-of-town reporters
were so they certainly didn't have
control anymore of what was being said
about Congress so the press is becoming
far more nationalized new
whose is becoming former nationalized
spreading further and faster than before
and these changes really stunned
congressmen they changed the immediate
local and national impact of what
congressman do in Congress they changed
how constituents interacted with their
congressman so in essence these
technological changes in the press
fundamentally change the nature of
congressional politics and you can see
this in an incident that took place in
1850 and actually it's the response to
the incident that shows this most
dramatically but I want to describe at
least what leads up to it and it's in
the Senate and it involves Thomas Hart
Benton of Missouri who's trying to forge
a national compromise on slavery and
Henry foot of Mississippi who's holding
firm on slavery and does not want that
kind of a compromise and Foote is
interested in defeating and discrediting
whatever Benton is saying and doing to
defeat and discredit his attempt at
compromise to do that Foote decides he's
gonna prove that Benton is not a real
southern man he's a traitor to the south
so he shouldn't be trusted his
compromise shouldn't be trusted and to
prove that Benton wasn't a real
southerner Foote began to bully him
insulting him and then essentially
saying things like are you willing to
duel me for that insult because you
should be and if you're not you're not a
real southern man he did this for days
and days and days in Benton actually
really tried to take it and eventually
Benton just snapped
quite literally threw back his chair
almost knocked over his desk lunged at
foot and foot who I think knew sooner or
later this was not going to end well had
armed himself in preparation for this
moment and pulled his gun and aimed it
at Benton which resulted in what one
senator called a stampede with
congressmen running over their desks
grabbing it both congressmen to hold
them back
trying to get their hands on the gun and
standing on chairs to see what was
happening and inevitably when fights
were happening particularly in the house
which was so large there were always
people standing on chairs on the floor
trying to see what was going on in the
committee reports reporting these fights
there's always people who say and then I
jumped up on my chair I couldn't see
what was happening in the
corner of the room now eventually things
calm down people took their seats and
here comes the moment where the press
and the changes in the press and its
implications come through people take
their seats and a New Hampshire senator
stands up and basically says excuse me
for interrupting here gentlemen but
before we begin again with whatever we
were talking about I feel the need to
say that thanks to the Telegraph within
an hour people all over America are
going to be reading that we're
slaughtering each other here in the
Senate and there's absolutely nothing
that we can do about that and you could
virtually hear the stunned silence
because he's right right that greets
that kind of a statement oh yeah we
actually have no control over the spread
of this news and but sure enough it's
gonna spread within an hour
technological changes through these
congressmen off balance news from the
National Center could reach people all
over the nation in a very short amount
of time and one of my favorite this is
my my offering of congressional trivia
for you to take away I am offering you a
gift of congressional trivia that will
be handy at cocktail parties in the
future it's it's relates to this idea
about people suddenly realizing that
they can communicate so much more
quickly with their constituents is so
much more directly and this involves the
word bunk which means claptrap and
nonsense the way we now use it that word
actually originated in Congress which
maybe isn't surprising I don't know but
the the source of it is really
interesting throughout this period
congressmen increasingly realized that
they could stand up and make speeches
aimed back home and not for each other
and early on in this discovery process
there was a congressman from North
Carolina who did this so frequently and
who found I think others found him to be
so tedious with it the frequency with
which he would stand up and say
something that was meant to be
inflammatory but not meant to be heard
on the floor that he would stand up and
say okay folks this is a speech for
Buncombe North Carolina and the other
congressmen would know okay we don't
really have to pay attention these
speeches came to be known as bunk home
speeches and you'll see in people's
letters you know well today was bunk
home day you know everyone stood up and
talked to their constituents and not to
each other
that word essentially gets shortened
down to bunk and that's where that word
comes from so I offer you that piece of
trivia to take away my little gift
you so congressional events are making
their way out to the nation including
Buncombe North Carolina faster than ever
before
and the reverse holds true as well
thanks to that same technology
congressmen know what their constituents
are thinking far more readily than
before and things that congressmen say
back home however extreme were winging
their way to the national center much
more quickly and easily than in the past
so for example in the 1850s
an anti-slavery congressman made a
really flaming anti-slavery speech back
home in Massachusetts and when he got
back to Washington and went back to
Congress a southerner rose during debate
and called him on it basically saying I
know what you said about the South back
in Massachusetts I've read it in the
paper I know that you called us savages
and barbarians do you really think you
can do that and then come back here and
take southerners by the hand and work
with us as colleagues and clearly this
southerner is saying the answer is no so
you can see how this sort of
technological changes are really
complicating congressional proceedings
which were and are fundamentally
grounded on community and compromise
Congress was sectionally polarized
national politics was sexually polarized
the press increasingly was becoming
sectionally polarized and politicians
hadn't yet figured out how to handle
this sort of newfangled press and you
can really see the impact of this state
of affairs in the north in this period
because not only were northerners
electing more anti-slavery congressmen
and more aggressively anti-slavery
congressmen but thanks to the
combination of polarized politics and a
more nationalized press northerners
began actively cheering on their
congressmen to fight in ways that they
never had before they had a better view
of what was going on in Congress they
could see their representative standing
up for their cause and they could see
more of the fighting because more of the
fighting was being reported they liked
what they saw and they told their
representatives that they liked it and
I've seen dozens of these letters from
constituents to their congressmen
basically saying in one way or another
fight them attack them at last there is
a north basically cheering on
northerners to fight southerners in
Congress and meeting it quite literally
most remarkably of all to me in the late
1850s some northerners were sending guns
to their congressmen telling them to
wear them on the floor so they'd show by
the late 1850s you had armed groups of
northerners and southerners running at
each other in the house and you had
reporters commenting that these brawls
looked remarkably like battles which
indeed they were in some ways you could
argue that the first battles of the
Civil War were fought on the floor of
Congress and the press was part of the
tangle of things that contributed to
this state of affairs now of course a
free press is also the very foundation
of a democratic politics and that's an
idea
certainly within our government that
goes back to even before the government
existed it goes all the way back among
other things to James Madison who said
very wisely right at the outset that
given how geographically extended this
Republic was given how large this nation
was the press basically had to be almost
a branch of government because it would
be the only way to enforce
accountability in this new government
the only way to connect people to each
other and their to the government and
vice versa
so the press is an essential part of
democracy so it makes sense that
dramatic changes in the press can
complicate a democratic politics so what
I'm talking about here is dramatic
technological innovations changing the
nature of the press making it more
responsive to the public making
congressmen more immediately accountable
making politics even more polarized and
changing the nature of Congress that's
happening in the 1850s and some version
of that is happening now which brings us
back to the present because I think in
the same way that the 19th century
Congress was figuring out how to handle
the telegraph the current Congress is
struggling to figure out how to handle
the internet and cell phones and 24/7
cable news coverage today as in the 19th
century technology has suddenly made the
connection between congressmen and their
constituents more immediate more direct
and Congress
and the public haven't quite figured out
what this means or how to handle the new
vulnerabilities and capabilities being
caused by it now obviously this is the
evocative and I think interesting
parallel that I mentioned at the
beginning of my talk
oddly enough the same anxiety and
confusion and grandstanding and
extremism that my nineteenth-century
congressmen were grappling with are in
the air again now as I said at the
outset I'm not offering answers here I'm
not offering advice here
equally important I'm definitely not
comparing the present day to the lead-up
to the Civil War there are vast
differences of politics of policies and
of party dynamics that make it
impossible to line up these two periods
as equivalent but what I am saying is
that technology plays an interesting and
I think sometimes underappreciated role
in the polarization of a democratic
politics and certainly it did in the
first half of 19th century and I think
this is a really interesting moment
because I think just in the last I don't
know 10 8 to 10 years we're watching
politics figure out what it can and
can't do with technology as well thank
you very much